how do you view fear how do you process
fear yourself especially the life you've
lived what is fear to you and how do you
treat it how do you manage it
i think fear is something which is very
important fear is something that you
have to have you know uh
and uh therefore uh you develop your
ability to uh
overcome that to surpass the fear that's
what make you a better man you know um
i don't trust people who say they are
not afraid
they have no fear i don't trust them
yeah because that fear is i mean fear
sometimes it's just a knowledge of a
situation that you're into and then you
have to be aware of the uh
dangerousity of that situation and be
careful and
as soon as you're aware of the danger
the that's the first step of your
defense but if you are not aware of it
that's
the first step step of your defeat
because you're exposed you think there's
not a danger
but
fear come and
acknowledge you that day something you
have to be careful
and therefore all your senses are ready
for whatever is coming to you so i think
fear is something that is very important
and
if you realize if you
look at it everything that you have done
in your life which is very important you
always have that fear that stress
you're always nervous even whether it's
like um apply for a job or uh go to a
i don't know
exam or whatever
everything that is very important you
have that fear because you have you
acknowledge that no there's something
important here i have to put all my
attention so that's what's kind of like
beautiful so the fight you had with
ghana when you went in when when when
were you able to control your nerves was
it the moment the fight started or
before you entered the octagon
i don't know if i would say i control
the nerves because um
at first i didn't understand and i
honestly at first i thought it was just
me i'm like man
how can i be so big and be
and she feel fear and be afraid
then with with experience i realized no
that's exactly how it works then i kind
of like check around then i realize
everybody has that feeling and that's
what made you a champion that's what
make you a fighter you're fighting
against uh
um
something that you're fighting against
yourself at first you know you're
fighting to overcome something to
surpass something there's a challenge
which is your fear that you have to
overcome you know and then therefore i
kind of like just manage just accept it
yes i'm afraid that's mean i'm ready
i'm aware that something no good is
coming off my way i'm in danger so okay
i have to defend myself i also trust my
ability to defend myself
you know so those combined kind of like
be like a
upside for me
when before when you're when you because
you're saying doctor maybe doctor's
right maybe this person's right maybe
that person like i shouldn't fight
the people that were telling you maybe
not to fight or the people that were
telling you to fight
when did you make the decision that you
were gonna fight was there ever a
breaking point that you said i'm not
gonna fight
uh no okay because even the first day
that the doctor
gave me a report after the mri
i think he was just expecting me to call
out the fight and
i didn't want to do anything at that
moment that i could have regret like
one or two weeks after and that was like
three weeks out
so i decided like okay i'm keeping this
moving on and see what's happened
if one week or two weeks after
it doesn't get any better or get worse i
think i have no choice
but
i mean
i still think
i mean
there was a part of me who also believed
that that could be a advantage on me to
be very uh to be to
feel that fear
to know that i know i'm not hundred
percent of my capacity and be very aware
of a danger
and at the moment that i'm aware of that
danger and on my um
on capacity i think i'm more uh
thoughtful
than when i'm like oh i'm good you know
let's go to war i'm like no don't do
that you're no good
you have to think about it differently
to approach it differently so if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]
you